who's by uh sushant is sachendra and
he's going to be talking about
a very exciting uh recent work on almost
linear time max flow and apparently
friends and
is a professor in university of toronto
and uh
you know his areas is fast algorithms
and optimization and uh he has been
actually one of a fellow in our first
program in 2013 in the simons institute
and i think you've been there you've
been here also one program but already
not as a fellow as a yeah i was a
visitor and uh in the theory of deep
learning in the theory of deep learning
and i'm extremely excited to hear about
this result because this is really the
breakthrough that we've had in
uh in algorithms theory in the last
decade big
thank you
please
you can hear me at the back great
thank you shafi for the kind words uh
it's an incredible honor to be here and
thanks to the organizers for putting
together this wonderful event
so i'll take this opportunity to tell
you about a recent work giving first
almost linear time algorithms for
maximum flow and related problems this
is joint work with some amazing
collaborators
lee who's in the audience here rasmus
yang richard and max
excellent so
maximum flow is a problem that needs
little introduction to this audience
and beyond but
let's just let me highlight a few things
we've been studying it for almost 70
years almost as long as we've studied
formal computation here's a citation
from 1955 trying to capture the capacity
of the soviet railway network as a max
flow problem and we've been studying it
intensely with good reason it's a
powerful algorithmic primitive you can
formulate lots of problems as instances
of maximum flow
right and that has meant that over the
past few decades it has become a test
bed for us to develop
new algorithmic ideas new algorithmic
perspectives
and we'll see a taste of it today
so a setup is
standard you have a directed graph with
m edges n vertices
two special vertices a source s and a
sink t
every edge has a non-negative capacity u
e
and for the purposes of this talk i will
assume it's an integer bounded between 0
and a polynomial
a polynomial in m let's say u capital u
is an upper bound on these capacities
so here i'm drawing an example graph
where the numbers in black give you the
capacities of these edges right and our
goal
is to send as much flow from the source
s
to
uh to the sink t
excellent so we will take
a linear algebraic perspective on flows
rather than the combinatorial you know
sums of paths let's take a linear
algebraic perspective what does that say
so for us
a flow is
a vector assigning a real number to
every edge
so in this example now these numbers in
purple
assign flow values to every edge
what constraints should we should they
satisfy so obviously we want the flow
value on the edge e to be non-negative
so it satisfies the direction and is
bounded above by the capacity
but that's not all it needs to be a flow
what does it mean what does it mean
so
to express that compactly i'm going to
change this graph slightly let me send
an edge from the sink back to the source
and on this special edge e sharp
i'm going to send
five units of flow which is the same as
the total flow going from the source to
the sink
okay so there's a special edge you send
the same amount of flow
now something has happened now i can now
what does it mean to be a flow
it means that at every single vertex
my net flow is exactly zero
the inflow is equal to the outflow
right
and with these constraints you exactly
capture all feasible flows
now i can formulate our goal just
slightly differently
send maximum amount of flow on this
special edge e sharp
while satisfying your constraints
and this gives us
a linear programming formulation for
maximum flow
right you want
over the space of all feasible flows
that are identified by your direction
and capacity constraints
and net flow constraints right so net we
said at every vertex you want inflow to
be equal to our flow that's a set of
equalities
one for each vertex that can be captured
by a system of linear equations
so that's your flow constraints
direction and capacity constraints
subject to these constraints you want to
send the maximum amount of flow
well maximizing the flow on e sharp is
the same as minimizing minus sufficient
why did i flip the sign
in order to achieve the minus and i will
show that to you at the next slide so
this is a it's a standard linear program
for maximum flow
this is the perspective we start from
and we give our main result which is
that in almost linear time we can solve
this linear program
and hence solve maximum flow
but our framework actually goes much
further uh
we can actually solve general convex
flows in almost linear time so what does
that mean
so over the space of
feasible flows so flows that satisfy net
flow constraints directionality and
capacity you can now minimize
any convex function that's representable
as a sum of convex fun functions of
flows of the edges
right this is it this this framework now
captures many many more problems and we
can essentially solve all of these
problems in almost linear time
so for the first time this gives us
almost linear time algorithms for very
many male well-studied problems
bipartite matching main cost flow
negative weight shortest path diffusion
worker transport optimal transport
matrix scaling isotonic regression
weighted p norm flows all of these
problems can be captured in this
framework and give you the first almost
linear time algorithms
okay so in the rest of the talk i hope i
will be able to give you a taste of how
we got there but to do that i should
first take a retrospective so this is
i mean
a half an hour talk would not be enough
to cover the the history of this problem
to do full justice but i'm going to try
to do it in one slide instead
so the purpose of this slide is to not
just highlight some of the main
developments but to take a retrospective
and in that retrospective i want to
highlight the paradigm shifts that came
along in thinking about maximum flow and
then extend it over to several other
algorithmic questions
so historically the perspective that has
been taken on maximum flow has usually
be was initially combinatorial so
starting from the work of ford and
fulkerson uh coming up to goldberg and
rao
that
these algorithms thought of flows
combinatorially and i want to say they
thought
you should think of them as having a
combinatorial inner algorithm and
combinatorial outer algorithm
okay this is not standard terminology
let me explain what i mean
so i hope all of you have seen the
augmenting paths algorithm so the
augmenting path algorithm says that
construct a residual graph
find an augmenting path
send some flow and repeat
in this classic algorithm i want to say
the inner algorithm is find an
augmenting path
and the outer algorithm says construct
the restaurant graph
and repeat right so i want to make this
distinction of inner and outer
algorithms and you can actually think of
all works on maximum flow in this outer
inner structure like all of them have
this outer inner structure so all of
these works up until good luck and now
essentially thought of them mostly
combinatorially the analysis of the
outer algorithm was also combinatorial
and after after this bound of m to the
1.5 that they achieved progress kind of
stalled for a long time
ten years later daichi and spearman
showed you could achieve the same bound
they didn't beat it but they showed you
could achieve the same bound by taking a
different approach
by looking at interior point methods
which give you a new outer algorithm so
they chose interior point methods as an
outer algorithm
which achieved root m iterations
for the outer algorithm
at the cost of a
more complicated inner problem in some
sense a numerical inner problem so the
problem the inner problem now became
minimizing l2 norm flows
since then since diet and spill men all
progress on maximum flow has it has
worked with interior point methods as
the outer algorithm
and
the and the inner problem has required
linear time
in all of these developments
there have been several i i can't even
take the time to spell them out but i
will highlight the main ones here and
the big focus has been trying to improve
the outer algorithm can we do
ipms with fewer and fewer iterations
but the in-ear inner algorithm has
stayed at linear time every iteration
over the past year there have been a
couple of works trying to improve the
cost of this inner algorithm that has
taken us hairline below 1.5 so the best
result before our work
was n to the 1.48
on sparse graphs
so in in this perspective here's where
how our work sits so we achieved the
first almost linear time algorithm
we work in the interior point framework
but we work with an outer algorithm that
now takes almost linear number of
iterations much more than previous works
right rather than root m
at this cost that the win is that we now
achieve a lot more combinatorial in our
problem
and that we can give and a dynamic data
structure to solve
the sequence of inner problems in almost
constant time per problem
okay so i in the rest of the rest of
this talk i hope to give you
a couple of key ideas that go into
uh go into our work
excellent so here's our first key idea
our first key idea is a new outer
algorithm which we call an l1 interior
point map
if you've not heard of inter point
methods don't worry i will introduce
everything here that we need to know
so interior point methods are a general
recipe to solve linear programs so say i
have a linear program identified by
linear
inequalities
inside this polygon your goal is to
minimize a linear cost function
right
interior point methods give an approach
to solve this in particular the first
potential reduction in ipm by a current
marker
approached it as follows karmaker
defined a potential on this politico
this potential consists of two terms you
don't have to follow the math but let me
just interpret this for you the first
the first term is a term that decreases
sharply in the objective
in the direction of the objective
the second term is what is known as the
log barrier term the log barrier term
keeps you away from the boundaries of
the polito right for every inequality
you add a term to keep you away from the
boundaries of the part
now when you sum this up you get a
smooth
potential defined in the interior of the
polytube i'm not sure if you can see
this but i've sort of drawn contours as
to how the potential is decreasing
so
this gives you a generic way of solving
linear programs so i will start from a
point f 0 that's somewhere in the
interior of this polytope i take a step
to f1 while decreasing the potential
take another step f2 and so on
as you keep taking steps it is
guaranteed that once the potential
becomes small enough
you are close to the optimum and hence
we can then just round to a vertex of
the polytope giving you the optimal
solution
right this is karmaker's uh potential
like it's it's a general recipe for ipms
but how did karmaker propose to solve
this so
so the main question i need to specify
is that if you are currently at a point
f you have a flow f how do you move to
the next iterate f plus delta
different recipes give you different
ipms
here's how kermarker proposed to take a
step said take my potential function and
write a second degree taylor expansion
okay so you write you expand out the
terms locally so you are at the point f
i will write a taylor's taylor expansion
of
the potential at f
that gives you three terms the first is
just constant that's your potential at f
the second is the linear term given by
the gradient of this potential function
and the third
is the l2 norm
quad the quadratic term
is l2 norm squared of l delta
what is this l here let's interpret so
so just so g is the gradient of the
potential l is something i'm defining
let me define it so
for every edge
let me define the symmetrized residual
capacity
what is that so i'm at you currently
have flow f e on edge e
i can either
remove
f e flow
before i violate the directionality
constraint or i can add u e minus f e
before i violate the capacity constraint
right on the edge i have these two
constraints you take the smaller of the
two
that's called symmetrized residual
capacity
you take the inverse of the symmetrized
residual capacity that gives me length
of the edges
right so for every edge e i'm defining
the length as the inverse of the
symmetrized residual capacity
and the second order taylor expansion
the quadratic term looks like
the length of the vector delta the
squared length of the vector delta
measured according to these lengths
right this is a it's a simple
computation of taylor expansion
now what's the recipe the recipe is as
follows that i will minimize this second
degree upper bound over all
circulations delta that i could add so
what is a circulation a circulation is
something that doesn't change the net
flow so the net flow of delta on every
vertex is exactly zero
so
this gives me the problem of electrical
flows
on on graphs well studied we won't go
there but it can be formulated as
follows overall circulation i give you a
gradient g and lens l
over all circulations give me the one
that minimizes the ratio of the gradient
term divided by the l2 length of delta
this is the electrical flow work and
and with the celebrated work of
dan spielman and shanghua
you can do this in almost linear time
right so and a lot of works were based
on
taking this approach
let's visualize what this is doing
geometrically so at the point f i've
drawn an ellipsoid given whose semi-axis
are given by the lens
in this ellipsoid i have a direction
given by the gradient g
i will find the point f plus delta that
stays within the ellipsoid but minimizes
the linear function and that's your next
iterate
this is car markers l2 ipa
okay
all of this is classic but so what did
we introduce we say
we are going to do this in l1
instead of an l2 norm square term focus
on this i'm going to upper bound this
with the worst term
the l1 norm square l1 norm squared of
delta so i'm measuring the length of the
vector in l and add the squared of the
length it's a worse upper bound
geometrically this means i'm going to
fit an l1 ball inside the ellipsoid
and i will move to the vertex of this l1
ball that minimizes the gradient
okay this gives me a different inner
problem that we call min ratio cycles
where over the space of circulations you
are minimizing the ratio of the gradient
term divided by the l1 length of the
step
right
so
so we've gone from l2 to l1 and hence
the name so let me take
just a minute to sort of interpret this
problem for us
so
min ratio cycle
you i'm giving you a gradient and
lengths on edges you want to find the
circulation that minimizes
the gradient term by the by the length a
key advantage of moving to l1 is that
now you can assume that the optimal
solution is actually just a simple cycle
on the graph it no longer has to be a
flow touching all edges it's just a
simple cycle on the graph
that's an advantage of going to l1 so as
an example here if i have a graph
and let's say my lens are in red
i also have gradients on the edges so
the numbers in black
are the gradient terms on the edges they
come with a direction
because the contribution of the gradient
term depends on the direction you are
traversing the edges so as in so let's
send one unit of flow along this cycle
the easy computation is what is its
length well its length is the red number
is 1 2 1 2 that's 6.
let's compute the gradient contribution
gradient contribution you have to be
careful focus on this edge in the center
with the number 4
the flow is opposite to the direction of
the gradient
so my contribution is actually minus 4
rather than 4 right so the sign of the
contribution depends on whether you
align with the gradient or you're going
opposite to the
grid right and then you can compute this
so if instead i
reverse the direction of the flow
the length would remain the same but the
gradient would change sign
right so in this sense this problem is
partly undirected and partly directed
so edges and lengths are undirected
that means i can traverse any edge in
either direction
you're not forced to traverse an edge
only in the direction
right you can traverse an edge in both
directions
however the gradient has a direction so
the contribution to the gradient term
now depends on which direction you're
going to traverse it
okay so this is our inner problem
so let me now just state what is the
guarantees of the outer algorithm that
we achieve so
we give the following outer algorithm so
it's an l1 ipm for maximum flow
that runs
in almost linear number of iterations
at every iteration you get an inner
problem to solve that's a min ratio
cycle
these are not just arbitrary problems
you
you for one you don't need to solve them
exactly
right you don't have to solve them
exactly if you solve them approximately
that's good enough very crudely so an
almost like m to the little one
approximation is good enough
these problems are changing slowly
my gradients and my lengths over the
entire algorithm only change and
like a total of
you only change coordinates total of
almost linear number of times right so
the gradients and the lengths are
changing very slowly throughout the
sequence and finally
if i'm currently at solution f and
there's a hidden f star that i want to
get to
this direction actually tells you that
my main ratio cycle has a good solution
right so this is guaranteeing that every
problem you solve actually has a good
solution given by the direction to the
optic
this is our key new outer algorithm
and this reduces our problem to now
solving
the this inner problem
solve
min ratio cycles approximately
okay and that's our inner algorithm
and
this is a big chunk of the paper that i
will not be able to tell you a lot about
but let me try to give you one vignette
as to what goes into trying to solving
this
so
what i'm going to do is i want to
motivate that because these are l1
problems
the experts here might identify hey can
i think of trees can we try to solve
them using trees and i'm going to show
you yes
you can use lots of ideas from trees to
try to solve these problems efficiently
okay and i'm going to show you the idea
by just showing you how do you solve a
single instance
i want to solve a single instance of
main ratio cycle so i've given you a
gradient
i've given you lengths to the edges you
want to solve you want to give me an
approximate solution to the main ratio
cycle
let me describe the algorithm to you in
two lines so what i'm going to do is i'm
going to sample a tree
from what are known as low stretch
spanning trees
these are very well studied objects
already in the context of algorithms
flows
uh
l2 flows
so
there exists a distribution on trees
from which you can sample on in linear
time
once you sample a tree
you check all the fundamental cycles of
this tree what is the fundamental cycle
of a tree you take the tree you add a
single off tree edge
if you add a single after edge you get a
unique cycle in the tree that's a
fundamental cycle
check
all the fundamental cycles and return
the one with the best ratio
that's my algorithm and you can do all
of this in almost linear time
okay and now i'm going to show you
that
this actually returns
a good approximate solution to the mean
ratio cycle
okay so let me show you how so the claim
is that the best cycle
is going to be a good approximate
solution to this min ratio cycle problem
so let's say i'll i'll do most of the
proof visually so let's say here's a
graph on this graph i sample a low
stretch spanning tree i haven't told you
what the guarantee is let me i'll tell
you in a second let's say the blue edges
identify the tree
the guarantee of a low stress spanning
tree
is that if you take an off tree edge
this thick black one here
then the fundamental cycle of this off
tree edge is not much longer than the
length of the edge itself
that's a guarantee of a low stretch
spanning tree it's not true for all
edges but it's true in expectation over
this distribution right when you sample
a tree it's true in expectation
so here's how we'll go
here's suppose
this green cycle is a hidden unknown
solution that's optimal to your mean
ratio problem
then
i'm going to sum up my guarantees of the
low stretch tree over all the edges in
this green cycle so if i sum up over all
all these edges outside those are off
three edges and sum up the guarantees
for the low stretch tree
it says that the sum of these
fundamental cycles corresponding to
these edges is not much longer than the
length of the cycle
right
this is true in expectation so well
linearity tells me it's
i can pull the expectation outside and
now i can apply markov
so with constant probability i'm
guaranteed that the sum of the lengths
of the fundamental cycles
is not much larger
than the length of the optimal solution
i don't know the optimization right but
it's not much larger
that's one the second key observation is
that now look at the gradient
contributions of each of these cycles so
for each of these black edges i have
this red
as the fundamental cycle
look at look at this blue edge tree edge
note that it gets cancelled
in one direction you are going
out and in the ear direction you are
going in
so the sum over all your tree edges is
going to cancel perfectly
so if you sum the gradient contributions
all you are left with is actually the
gradient contribution of the optimal
cycle
so what have we shown if you look at
this set of optimal cycles
the length is not much more
the sum of the gradients is the same
so by averaging actually one of them
must be
a good solution
right a good approximate solution
and well this was constant probability
but you can boost it by sampling very
many trees
okay
so this shows you that by sampling
one
low stretch spanning tree you can you
can solve this problem
that's of course not enough you need to
solve
very many problems in almost linear time
that's something i'm not going to be
able to tell you about
but let me sort of state what do we show
so we show that we can maintain a data
structure that maintains a few trees
right not one tree but a small
collection of trees
that supports the following operations
one
you can change the gradients or lengths
in a small amount of time almost
constant time per change right because
our problems are changing we need to
update these
under these changes you can return an
approximate solution
right and finally
once you find such a cycle you can route
flow along
that's our data structure for solving
the inner pro the sequence of inner
problems effectively
and now you put these two together to
give our overall algorithm here's what
the structure looks like
so i'm going to maintain this data
structure that
maintains a few trees
there's an outer loop of almost linear
number of iterations
at each iteration you get updates to
your gradients and lengths
we use these updates to change our trees
with these trees you find a circulation
an approximate solution to your min
ratio cycle you send flow along this and
now you repeat
right so i mean in some sense
at the end it feels poetic that we've
all come down to a sequence of
trees and sending flows along cycles
okay so
with that let me summarize so you can
now we gave a new outer algorithm which
is an l1 ipm you combine that with a new
data structure for solving this inner
mean ratio cycle problems
and that can the same recipe cannot just
solve max flow but very many
convex flow problems in almost linear
time
uh with that i'd like to just thanks the
simon institute for this opportunity and
the numerous opportunities that they
provide to our community and the
wonderful service they've been doing
in particular there was an entire
program focused around
continuous methods for algorithms
and thank you again for inviting me here
thanks
good so the question was how do you know
when you're done and
one one good way to see is we were
measuring this potential function
so when you when the potential function
is small enough you know that the
solution is guaranteed to be close to a
vertex and at that point you can just
round the flow edge by edge
another question
yes so
what happens if you use l2 ipm
ah good uh that's that's a very good
question so the
the question is what happens if you were
instead working with the l2 ip so the
first obstacle so many many many
algorithms were trying to continue
working with the l2 ipm which is the
standard approach
the first observation is that
you need to every solution to the inner
problem has to touch all the edges
you can't just get by with touching a
very small fraction of the edges so your
so your problems are dense and secondly
when going from one problem to another
the solution changes dramatically we do
not know how to update the solutions
effectively
to be able to accumulate them right and
that that was the approach the previous
ones had been trying it only could shave
like you know 0.02 in the exponent so n
to the one point four eight rather than
getting to almost linear
i mean l two ibm's are actually strictly
better they take a better approximation
but the cost is you get an algorithm
like a sub problem that's
more expensive to solve
changes more rapidly right so what we're
doing is we're doing a tradeoff we we
solve we take a worse ipm
but now the sub problem is changing more
slowly and we can we can we can get a
handle over it rather than rather than
the electrical flows
so my question is it's randomized right
i mean have you thought about that the
algorithm is randomized uh we we sort of
have no
uh no idea how to de-randomize it it's
funny i've actually told you the main
place we don't know how to get rid of
randomization that's the markov's
inequality that's the hardest place we
don't know how to get rid of
randomization
no
so max flow is such an important problem
in practice that there are incredibly
engineered softwares that can handle
millions of edges per second on a
computer
there's no way any implementation of
this is going to get close
might it be worth to take some of these
ideas and work with trees instead yes
but i think we are very far from
something that would work well
okay thank you very much again
[Applause]
so our next speaker is the last one
before lunch is professor daniela